welcome thank you okay so first I want
to thank the organizers for this this
workshop this nice workshop thank you
and for also the organization of this
semester
very interesting so today I want to talk
about diagrammatic reasoning and we have
heard already about this we have seen
several talks about diagrammatic
reasonings but string diagrams networks
hypergraph categories higher categories
and opiods and probably others talks
that i'm missing so i want to talk about
this kind of graphical language but in
particular in the case of quantum
mechanics and quantum information
processing quantum computing and the
question that I want to address here is
the completeness of this kind of
languages that is if you have a
graphical language which is complete it
means that you can just forget all the
other formalisms that you can have so
for internal quantum case you can just
forget matrices hilbert spaces and all
this kind of complicated things and just
work with a simple intuitive graphical
language that would be great right and
so if it is complete now if it is
incomplete means that there are some
properties of quantum mechanics that you
are not capturing with your language so
it means that there is some room for
improvement you can try to find some new
rules and new structures which are
satisfied by quantum mechanics so in
fact it's also exciting to to to find a
and incompleteness results but it turns
out that this is a hard question in
general and often we just don't know you
just don't know if the language is
complete or not so today I want to show
you some new result in fact some new
results of incompleteness and this is a
joint work with Emmanuel Jean del
Donovan MA and Harney Wong okay so
what's the context so I'm going to use
the ZX calculus which is this graphical
language introduced by Bob cooker and
rostam can and we
nice talk yesterday about the
introduction about this language an
introduction on this language so we have
this kind of diagrams who is a inputs on
the top and outputs on the bottom this
is the domestic point of view and we
have two kinds of dots green dots red
dots with which are parameterize by an
angle and if there is no angle it means
that this angle is just zero so this is
a nice graphical language with a wide
spectrum of applications from
foundations of quantum mechanics for
instance the fact that spatial dagger
for binos algebras are capturing the
notion of autonomic bases or that of
algebras are capturing the notion of
complementarity that is the uncertainty
principle essentially we have this kind
of results more we have seen giulio
using this kind of not exactly this one
but this kind of graphical diagrams to
graphical language to talk about the
axiomatization of quantum mechanics and
actually even more general theories so
there are some foundations applications
but this language also aims to be a
practical tool for quantum information
processing with this language you can
actually prove protocols you can use
this language to develop error
correcting code and actually dominic
osmani is actually using the ZX calculus
in order to develop some new error
correcting codes for the practical
quantum computer so it is developing
error correcting codes which are working
with a limited memory and which are very
efficient and this language is coming
with a software quantumatic that you can
use to describe this kind of diagrams
and reason on this on these diagrams
right so if you are interested you can
have a look to this this page and
actually we have seen quantumatic in
action yesterday during row system
okay so this language is used to
represent quantum evolutions and this is
actually a universal language can
represent any quantum evolution using
this language so how does it work each
qubit is representing sorry each wire is
representing the qubit and and well so
okay so there is a limitation actually
since each wire is representing a qubit
what you can represent with a finite
diagram is a finite qubit quantum
evolution okay so that's why this
language is universal for finite qubit
quantum mechanics so if you want to know
what is the quantum evolution which is
represented by this diagram you can
compute the semantics that it's a matrix
describing the content eeveelution and
in order to know what is the matrix you
cut your diagram into pieces and you can
just decompose the diagram like this and
then you have a look to the semantics of
the language for each basic element and
like this you can compute the matrix
associated with this diagram okay so
this is the semantics of the language
okay
okay so this language is coming with
some rules to transform the diagrams so
for instance we have the spider which
tells you that whenever you have two
green dots which are connected you can
merge them and you add the angles you
have some other equation saying that
when you have a green dot with degree
two with just two legs you can just
remove this dot for instance you have
the same rules for red dots and you have
some other rules for the interactions
between the green dots and the red dots
like this actually these these these
rules are now well understood actually
these kind of equations on the top
corresponds to the fact that we are
working with a special dagger Frobenius
algebra so as I said before it captures
the notion of autonomic bases this is a
result by Jamie and Bob and Bob Kocher
and do Schiaparelli and so this one here
responds to the fact that we have op
hope algebras and it captures the notion
of complementarity of the bases well
just a remark in general in algebra we
don't have these this kind of things so
here this diagram with no input and no
output is actually a scalar just a
complex number
so here the Bansha Brown this is called
by a bra so we have the usual battery
block cut to a normalization here and
this diagram here the normalization is
actually root 2 okay so we have a good
understanding of this kind of rules
right it punches out interesting
structures in quantum mechanics but it
turns out that this is these rules are
not enough to capture all the properties
of a qubit quantum mechanics we need
some additional rules so for instance we
need this rule which is about scalars so
diagrams with no input and output and so
here the interpretation of this diagram
which is the empty diagram so it's
representing just the scale of 1 to
complex number one so here these rules
tells us that
here actually this diagram is the
inverse of this one all right and since
I said that this one is root 2 this one
is 1 over root 2 we have other axioms
like this one so this one actually this
scalar is interesting because it's 0 how
you encode the cannot 0 and here it's
the absorbing properties of the 0 and
you have other axioms for angles by
commutation and these kind of things
there are a few other actions that here
you have a representative set of of the
axioms of the language ok so we have
this this language and the question is
is it complete that is do we have all
the possible rules can we prove
everything using this rules or or not
so the completeness formally means that
if you take two diagrams D 1 and D 2
which are representing the same matrix
so the same content evolution is it
actually possible to prove using the
rules of the language that d1 is equal
to d2 this is the completeness property
ok so there is a series of Frizzles
about the completeness of the ZX
calculus so the first result I want to
show you is a negative result this is a
result by vladimir sam jeff and
christian Schroder they showed that
actually the ex calculus is not complete
some equations that are not provable
with this language and the bad news is
that actually there is a no obvious way
to extend the language to complete the
language or at least to try to add some
new equation to the language ok so the
entire language is not complete but now
if you just consider a sub language and
this is what million becomes did so she
considered the PI by two fragment of the
language which consists in considering
only the diagrams where the angles are
multiple of PI by 2 so you have this
restriction on the angles and it turns
out that she proved that it's complete
for this fragment the language is
complete so that's
that's an interesting result and but
here the bad news is that actually this
is probably too restrictive and we lose
the universality of the language that is
there are some quantum evolutions that
cannot be represented in this fragment
they can not even be approximated with
this fragment and actually for instance
if you have a quantum algorithm which is
described in this fragment it turns out
that this quantum algorithm can be
efficiently simulated on a classical
computer so for quantum computing this
is not what you want to to do right so
we need something more more expressive
and the interesting fragment is actually
the PI by 4 fragment so you're resting
the angles to be multiple of PI by 4 yes
it means that actually ok so for the
proof of incompleteness is constructive
so there is a pair of diagrams which are
representing the same metrics and it
turns out that you cannot prove that
they are equal but it turns out that in
this particular example the angles here
are not multiple of PI by 2 so when you
restrict the angles you are just this
this contra example doesn't work ok so
that's how you can get the completeness
okay so okay so the pie for fragment
this is what you want to work with
because this fragment is a universal any
quantum evolution can be approximated by
diagram in this fragment and there are
some notions of efficiency so this is
really what you want to work with and so
Miriam begins again managed to prove the
completeness of this fragment but with a
very strong assumption which is that the
diagram all the dots are of degree at
most two yes it means that essentially
the diagram you are working with or just
path from the inputs to the outputs so
it's just local operations so it's very
restricted but at least at least it's
it's complete for this this particular
case okay but for the PI by four
fragment in general it turns out that
it's incomplete and here is the
candidate for the incompleteness in fact
the the candidate is the property which
has been pointed out by Bob cook and
Bill Edwards which is called
supplementarity if you take this diagram
so with so you have a red dot and these
two green dots and the angle R there is
an anti-phase here you have alpha alpha
plus PI they are connected together you
can actually merge them you can fold
this this diagram into this one where
the angle is the sum of the two angles
okay and so if you look at the matrices
it turns out that for any alpha this is
true the two matrices are the same but
is it probable in the language right
this is the candidate for the incomplete
set in completeness and we proved
recently with only one that actually no
you cannot prove this this equation as
soon as the angle is not a multiple of
PI by 2
there is no way to prove this supreme
entirety using the rules of the language
on the ZX captures
so we need this condition because when
alpha is a multiple of pi by 2 we know
that it's complete okay so it's provable
when alpha is PI by 2
but when alpha is PI by 4 it's not
provable so it proves that the PI by 4
fragment is not complete ok but ok so
now the idea is that we have identified
this equation which is not provable in
the language so let's add this new
equation the supreme authority to the
language and now we consider ZX Calculus
plus the supplementarity and we wonder
if this language is complete ok so now
i'm going to show you some new results
about this this completeness and the
answer is no it's not complete and i'm
going to show you several examples
actually an infinity plus 1 control
example ok so let me start with the 1 ok
it's easier so this is the the example
so here we have a so complete for the PI
by 4 fragment I should have said here or
in general so here we are in the PI by 4
fragment we have this diagram and if you
compute the semantics of this scatter it
turns out that it's 1 so it's the same
as the empty diagram and I claim that we
cannot prove this equation in the
statics calculus and actually the proof
is simple so I'm going to show you the
proof it's based on an invariant and
this environment is the following
even the diagram we compute this
quantity which is the parity of the
number of greened legs so the degree of
the green dots so in your diagram you
consider all the green dots and you sum
the degree of these green dots so the
number of inputs outputs of these green
dots and you take it modulo 2 so it's
the parity of the number of green legs
and it turns out that if you take this
language the x calculus and the supreme
authority rule it turns out that all the
actions of the language are satisfying
this invariance
and actually it's not an accident
because in the PI by two fragment this
this environment must be satisfied so
it's not an accident right
so it's satisfied and here it's easy to
compute this invariant on this side we
have just one green dot which is of
degree 1 so it's 1 and on the other side
there is nothing so it's zero so the
environment is not satisfied for this
particular role so it means that you
cannot prove it using the ZX calculus ok
so we have identified a new one ok ok so
I'm just going to use some notation for
the talk I've talked about the super
mentality but these rules so I'm going
to add these two axioms to the ZX
calculus and call it Z X prime ok and
just a remark so by doing this we are
increasing the power of the language but
we are also increasing the number of
axioms but actually two axioms of the ZX
calculus can actually be derived if you
have these new rules so instead of
adding new action we can just replace
these two axioms here by these two new
axioms and we get a language which is
more expensive more expressive but
without increasing the number of axioms
ok
ok so I said that I going to show you an
infinite number of contracts ample so
here are the candidates for the the in
completeness and in fact it's based on a
generalization of the supreme entirety
so here it's the Superman charity I
remind you so when you have this this
kind of green dots you can merge them
together and it turns out that we can
generalize it if we have now three
branches three dots with where the
angles are alpha alpha plus 2 5 by 3
alpha plus 4 PI by 3 we can also merge
that ok it also works if you look at the
matrices it's they are representing the
same matrix and so on for branches it's
also working and so on and branches
right so okay so just a remark about the
angles that you have here in the green
dots
actually it's they should be uniformly
distributed on the circle on the unit
circle so it should remind you the roots
of unity okay sing like this so the
distance between two green dots should
be the same okay it's the angle is
always 2 pi by n into consecutive dot
okay so we have some candidates here but
is it actually the case that we can not
prove this using the Z excuse let's take
an example if I use the if I consider so
the supreme entirety with four branches
this is this one alpha are 4 plus PI by
2 alpha plus PI alpha plus 3 PI by 2
here it turns out that we have alpha and
alpha plus PI so for these two dots I
can apply the Superman charity the usual
the simple supreme entirety with two
dots right so I can take this one and
this one and merge them into a single
one and I can do the same with the these
two with alpha plus PI by 2 alpha 3 PI
by 2 I can also merge them and actually
I not give you all the details of the
proof but you can continue like this and
at the end of the day you managed to
prove that it's actually this equal to
this one okay so this one is not a
control example for branches is not a
counter example using super mentality
with two branch the two branches you can
prove the supreme integrity with four
branches okay so what is the structure
here actually it's the following that is
if in the set X primer if you assume
that you have the sacrament arity with n
branches and the supreme authority with
M branches you are able to prove super
mentality with n times M branches so we
have a structure here they are not
independent somehow all these properties
and we have the following structure
okay so since we have these kind of
structures the interesting case are the
prime numbers because if the number is
not prime you can decompose it and prove
it with smaller cases and it turns out
that for prime numbers you should take P
prime number there is no way to prove
the supreme entirety with P branches and
actually we are proving that even if you
consider that you have the supreme
entirety with hugh branches for any
prime number q different from P it's not
possible to prove the supreme authority
miss P so supreme integrity with P
branches is a contour example to to the
the completeness of the language so here
we have an infinite number of contour
examples and they are all independent
right if you see some of them you cannot
prove the others okay so to sum up we
have introduced two new and necessary
rules for the ZX calculus so this
generalized supreme integrity and this
pie by four rule it turns out that the
language is still not complete the
Vladimir's proof does not work directly
but you can patch it and actually prove
that even if you have these two new
equations the language is not complete
so what is the future work well one
point is to try to find a meaning some
more insights about this new rule
because we have this new rule okay we
know that it's we need this kind of fool
but what is the meaning is there a
physical meaning for this kind of things
is there can we represented in a
categorical way is there there are some
structures behind these I don't know
another point is that actually here we
have a schema of fools with this
parameter N and 2d when N is increasing
this this role is becoming very large
that is in order to apply this this rule
for a parameter n means that you have to
find in your diagram and dots which are
satisfying these conditions okay so
somehow it's a unbounded okay
so is there an alternative set of foods
which are bound into acting on at most
five dots or something like that a
question which is related to this one is
the implementation of this kind of rule
the generalized supplementarity in
quantumatic it seems that it's not of
use to implement this kind of force in
quantumatic because it's more general
than the previous ones and again the the
this general question about the
completeness of the pie for fragment is
it enough to add this this equation to
make the language complete for the pie
for fragments we don't still open okay
thank you for your attention
his semantic authority of diagram say
with rational with fractions of pie
decidable is it even recursively
enumerable what do you mean a way to
prove the incompleteness for instance or
just for these particular cases given
two diagrams decide a very cool separate
from any issue of axiomatization I'm
just wondering if that equality is the
sine of one and let's say with just with
rational with sort of fractions of five
yes yes oh yeah in that case
[Music]
is decidable in the oil of PI over to
case so mu in beckons paper she's crazy
yes so there should be a more general
thing but not big well not the Equality
so here we are not talking about
completeness right it's just to decide
whether it's provable or not it's true
according to the axioms of the language
not not about the so we're asking given
two diagrams and I decide if matrices
are equal yes but to compute it you need
two representation of de D angles and so
on
the comments said just to answer this so
they did the matrix is going to be
exponential in the site of the diagram
potentially not necessary but
potentially so well so the complexity is
probably expected to be high but they
should be a translation it I don't know
I haven't proved that this but it
depends on the encoding of the angles
and so on maybe and for a model of some
situation that's not exactly similar
exactly the same that is some
philosophical relation back in the
seventies there was the question of
completeness or incompleteness of
certain logics of programs was posed and
the problem there was that you were
working with a few rules with some
simple objects and so on but everything
was happening on top of say the theory
of natural numbers so the whole thing
would become trivially you know you
would fall in in girdles infinite bit of
if you just encoded everything gay
matter now it's however if you look at
that work there is a concept of relative
completeness relative incompleteness
that could be possibly something similar
can be devised here so you can isolate
this nice set of maybe finite set of
simple manipulation rules from the more
complicated mathematical semantics
that's under here okay essence